by this point self-driving cars are
pretty common sight in Mountain View
California after all Google's been
working on the technology since 2009 and
this week its fleet of nearly 60
autonomous cars hit a milestone they
have now clocked more than two million
miles of autonomous driving on public
streets the tech giants still won't say
when its cars will be ready or how
they'll be used but the 2 million mark
is a reminder that while lots of players
have run onto the field Google is still
the veteran it's car sees the world with
a combination of cameras radar and laser
sensors but the real work is building
the software that translates that
information into the way it drives and
that's where real world experience is
crucial when I wrote an uber
self-driving car last month in
Pittsburgh the human engineer had to
take over a few times in 30 minutes of
driving around Mountain View Google's
car did every moment of the driving yes
the suburb is a simpler environment than
the city of bridges but - a few moments
of jerky braking Google's car really
rivals an experienced human okay so we
don't know how the tech giant is going
to bring this technology to customers
but sitting behind what future
generations will remember as the
driver's seat I'm already losing sight
of who's in control